foreign
hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again
so a while back if you guys remember I
think it was a movie retrospective that
we did probably several months to a year
ago
so we did a review of the classic 1962
film whatever happened to Baby Jane
and after we watched that I kind of went
a little bit down
of a little bit of a mini Rabbit Hole I
guess about the small but potent
psychobitty sub-genre which is also
known by the delightful name of hag
exploitation
so you can probably guess just from the
names like what these movies involve but
on the off chance that you can't uh
they're basically horror films Thrillers
where the antagonist is Like A demented
old woman uh usually specifically one
that used to be beautiful and glamorous
like back in the old days but has since
gone completely off the deep end and has
just become crazy and or murderous so
other examples other than whatever
happened baby Jane would be like 1964's
Hush Hush sweet Charlotte
um whatever happened to Aunt Alice from
1969 which a lot of these titles are
very very similar
um and 1971's what's the matter with
Helen which actually happened to be
directed by the same guy Curtis
Harrington who directed the movie that
we're talking about on this video today
uh Curtis Harrington incidentally also
he directed a bunch of movies including
Ruby from 19 77 with Piper Laurie which
you haven't seen that is actually pretty
good is that I don't think I'd
necessarily call that hack exploitation
but it's a similar kind of thing uh he
also actually directed the pretty great
and sadly fairly underrated 1961 film
night tied which I think I reviewed on
this flickers of fear series like some
time ago and he also did the 1970 uh
psychological horror film which I think
was made for TV which was called how
awful about Alan which starred Anthony
Perkins which is another movie that I
kind of want to get around to doing one
of these days so the movie that we're
talking about today though is called who
slew Auntie Rue
um although I will note that in the UK
and on the title screen it's actually
whoever slew Auntie Rue so this was
released in 1971 and stars Shelley
Winters as the psycho bitty in question
uh this is actually based somewhat on
Hansel and Gretel you know the fairy
tale and set around the holidays so who
slew Aunty Rue uh totally counts totally
counts as a Christmas this horror movie
which is why I specifically chose to
watch it in December and review it
around this time period now I will say
right from the outset that this is not a
great movie by any stretch but it is a
lot of campy fun and does feature just
like a whole [ __ ] you know horse
stable full of recognizable British
actors because this I believe even
though it was American International
pictures I believe was the distributor
but this was actually a US UK
co-production that was shot at
shepperton studios in London now I don't
think about the time period of the story
like specifically the year is ever
stated explicitly but it seems to be
taking place around maybe like the end
of the 19th century or the or the
beginning of the 20th century the whole
vibe of it is very dickensian you know
what I mean uh and especially more
because it's like set at Christmas time
so there's a bunch of adorable little
Muppets who live at an orphanage in
whatever picturesque Village this is
taking place in and every year uh the 10
best behaved of them are selected to go
to this big lavish Christmas party which
is hosted by a local Widow named Rosie
Forrest who's obviously played by
Shelley Winters now all the kids every
year like jockey to go because Mrs
Forrest lives in this big massive
mansion that looks a little bit like a
gingerbread house you know there's that
Hansel and Gretel thing again and she
always lays out this big massive spread
of food and buys really nice expensive
gifts for all of the children that are
lucky enough to be invited to the party
so Mrs Forrest by the way was apparently
once quite a well-known stage actress
back in her younger days but she gave up
her career to marry a very wealthy and I
guess world famous magician who has
since died or gone to the other side of
the mirror as she puts it
um so basically it seems like he left
her all his money so the couple also had
a daughter named Catherine
but Catherine also died in a tragic
accident sometime before involving a
staircase banister and Mrs Forrest has
understandably never really gotten over
it so whenever she feels especially
lonely or vulnerable or whatever she
calls up her favorite medium whose name
is Mr Benton and he's played by the
legendary stage actor sir Ralph
Richardson who actually played the
Supreme Being in that Terry Gilliam
movie Time Bandits from 1981 I mean
among many other roles he's mostly known
as like a Shakespearean or like a stage
actor but he has been he's been in some
movies I think he was also in Dragon
Slayer now that I'm thinking about it
but yeah so she has Mr Benton come over
to do a seance and contact the ghost of
her dead daughter so she can like talk
to her unbeknownst to Mrs Forrest though
uh Mr Benton has been faking these
Spirit Communications the whole time uh
actually with the help of two of the
household servants who actually like
take a cut of his fee like Mrs Forest
pays you know pays him and then he
breaks off little bit for his little
Confederates there so on this particular
Christmas uh 10 of the orphans as usual
are selected to go to the party but the
Troublemaker Christopher who's actually
played by Mark Lester who was in a lot
of stuff as a kid he was an Oliver he
was in black beauty stuff like that and
his younger sister Katie who's played by
Chloe Franks she was actually in a bunch
of horror and Thriller type movies she
was in the house had dripped blood she
was in Straw Dogs she was entails from
the Crypt the Anthology movie
um yeah so that brother and sister are
not among the children who get chosen
because I guess they've been bad this
year so because they feel a little bit
cheated and overlooked and think this
whole thing is [ __ ] they decide that
they're gonna stow away in the back of
the carriage or vehicle that's taking
the kids to Mrs forrest's house now not
too long after arriving at the Mansion
they get busted by the ever so slightly
unhinged Butler whose name is Alby and
he's played by Michael Gothard I guess
that's how you pronounce his last name
he was in the Ken Russell movie The
Devils he was in life force the Toby
Hooper movie from the 1980s you know the
one with the naked space vampire he was
in that as well
um so yeah so this guy like catches them
and actually like threatens to cut out
the boy's tongue and looks as though
he'd really like have a good time doing
that so you know but when Alby brings
the two kids into the living room like
Mrs Forrest doesn't seem upset at all by
these two stowaways
um and kind of figures hey whatever like
the more the merrier she's got money
she's got plenty of food blah blah it's
not really that big a deal
um probably contributing to her somewhat
chill attitude toward these you know to
two little miscreants like showing up is
the very close resemblance of the little
Katie to Mrs forrest's dead daughter
so as the night goes on I'm presuming
it's Christmas Eve they have like a
fantastic time all the kids do stuffing
themselves such as roast turkey and
gingerbread and cranberries and all the
good stuff then Mrs Forrest reads them
towards the night before Christmas and
then kind of sends them all tucks them
all into bed you know nobody get up it's
like you'll see what Father Christmas
brought you in the morning and [ __ ] like
that Christopher though is suspicious of
Mrs forrest's motives like yeah sure she
seems very warm and kind and generous
and all of that but Christopher's little
he's very sharp-eyed he's very nosy and
he sees a few odd things around the
place uh such as he sees a woman in a
like a Supply Closet type thing
pretending to be the voice of a ghost
um during one of Mrs forrest's seances
and even more alarmingly than that Mrs
Forrest herself like he kind of sneaks
around and sees her done up like all in
Victorian morning clothes and she's
talking to the the mummified remains of
a little girl that are like stashed in
this secret Nursery room up in the attic
so later on Mrs Forrest actually asks
Katie the little girl if she'd like to
stay with her indefinitely and be her
new daughter and although she doesn't
say it outright she seems to imply that
Katie's brother Christopher uh is not
invited to be a part of this little
package deal that she's proposing
Katie though doesn't really seem to give
a she's all about it um she's basically
like hey Mrs Forrest is nice to me I
mean you know she's an orphan she's like
she's nice to me she gave you know she
gave her like a big huge teddy bear
named William uh who's just like one
that she used to have when she was
littler gives her all kind of like
delicious food like plays with her plays
tea with her and stuff like that
promises her like a comfortable life of
just Endless Love and luxury so you know
what's not to like so when the staff
from the orphanage arrive on what again
I presume is boxing day because they
actually stay over like a night or two
so you know so the orphanage people come
to like collect the children and take
them back to the home Katie is nowhere
to be found and Mrs Forrest claims to
have no idea where that little Scamp
could have gotten off to now Christopher
at this point tries to tell the adults
that Mrs Forest like straight up
kidnapped his sister but since Mrs
Forest is a beloved local figure and
Christopher is known to be something of
kind of like a little bit of a tear away
who makes up stories and lies and stuff
no one really believes him Mrs Forrest
says oh yeah I'll absolutely keep an eye
out for Katie uh no two ways about it
and then she's like bye see you guys uh
later later that night though uh
Christopher sneaks out of the orphanage
and makes his way back to the mansion uh
you know pretty much dead set on
rescuing his sister now when he gets
into the house he finds his sister very
happily like playing up in the nursery
and seemingly not terribly concerned
about going back to the Children's Home
even though Mrs Forrester is essentially
like keeping her prisoner she's pretty
much like locked in this one room but
she's just like whatevs like all the
toys and food are here so what's the
what's the difference now Christopher
because he had recently read Hansel and
Gretel to Katie he's become convinced
that Mrs Forrest is a witch who is
planning on eating them and subsequent
events only kind of cement this
suspicion in his mind one of these being
like Mrs Forrester or keeps repeatedly
like sending Christopher out to get more
and more firewood so that the stove can
be like extra hot for whatever it is
that she's planning on cooking like
she's got all her recipe books and she's
making some stuffing and she's obviously
like planning something and he's like
yeah it's gonna be like a children roast
is what he's is what he's afraid of now
as I mentioned this isn't a particularly
scary film but it does kind of have its
trashy charms I have to admit uh Shelly
Winters is pretty over the top she kind
of straddles the line between
a sort of pitiable has been I guess and
a little bit of a delusional monster but
she's still kind of like sympathetic for
all of that but she never really reaches
the sort of exalted horrorific Heights
of you know like Betty Davis and
whatever happened to Baby Jane who's
actually like kind of terrifying
um you know and that's the movie that
this was clearly inspired by now the
holiday setting around this I really
liked that it's very effective though I
will say too that this isn't even as
frightening as like any of the versions
of A Christmas Carol with the terrifying
ghosts and stuff I did like the seances
I like that kind of setup and I liked
the mummified corpse aspect I think this
stuff would have been scarier if more of
it was filmed at night or in like a more
shadowy kind of thing but it's very
a lot of it takes place in the day or in
very well-lit rooms and I think that
kind of like undercuts its creepiness a
little bit even though some of the
imagery and the ideas behind it are kind
of creepy I just wish it could have been
like you know just filmed in a more like
creepy or more horror Type of Way
um there was also like um a good scene
where Christopher and Katie discover
this shed that has some of um Mr
forrester's old magic tricks in it and
one of these includes a working
Guillotine that uh really should have a
safety warning on it or a safety bar or
something like that because they're all
thinking oh it's a magic trick and it's
fake and you know Christopher tells his
sister hey get in there we'll try it out
it's like luckily she pulls her head out
at the last second but like puts the
teddy bear in that cuts the teddy bears
hat off so it's an actual Guillotine
that doesn't even have anything like
around it to like warn you hey don't
stick your head in here because it'll
actually like cut it off I was like holy
[ __ ]
um so yeah so there's that that was
actually like a really cool scene and
Ralph Richards is also really
entertaining as the scamming medium
um though I kind of wish he'd been in it
a little bit more he's not in it a great
deal
um the child actors I'd say pretty good
for this kind of thing
um you know like I said these child
actors were quite famous like for the
era like they were better known child
actors they were in a lot of things like
when they were kids and one thing that I
do wish like other than this being like
I wish it had been filmed a little bit
more creepy like rather than everything
just being in these well-lit rooms I
wish that the look of the film would
have leaned a little more into the fairy
tale concept because seeing as how this
was essentially based on Hansel and
Gretel I kind of wish that it had gone
slightly more I'm not saying that it had
to go like in a more fantasy kind of way
but I wish the look of it had been a
little more Fantastical if that makes
any sense but I guess this was actually
sort of meant to be uh you know more of
a realistic take on the story and not
something that was that had like any
fairy tale kind of aspects to it so I
will say though if you've kind of seen
all the more classic you know Christmas
horror movies and are look looking for
something that's very Christmas specific
but has more of like a 70s TV movie Vibe
you know then this might just be your
cup of tea you might dig it
um it's kind of like a Christmassy
mashup of like Charles Dickens like The
Brothers Grimm and maybe like a low rent
Sunset Boulevard or something like that
like I said it very much has that psycho
Bill psycho bitty kind of uh vibe to it
so you'll probably have a good time with
it if this is a Christmas movie that you
haven't really seen like you know if
you've seen some of the other ones then
check it out it's a lot of fun actually
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear I'll see you guys again on the next
one bye